hello freak [ __ ] savile yeah I think
that lost a lot of no that's not the
reason there's TV watch that's not the
reason the reason it's not the reason
Jesus Chrysler so yeah yeah I've been
dealing with some people are [ __ ]
idiots I get it you know I know I've had
to be like really really specific over
there there is a group of people online
who know that I'm right and they don't
like them right they don't like you're
right oh no they hate that I'm are we
talking about new sarkeesian again a
family they hate me and I don't give
them any more ammunition my house so bad
that she's not defending herself or she
won't never be hey bruh - no [ __ ] when
she when she called me a piece of [ __ ]
in the garbage human I had said nothin
happen so that's like so GL back I just
want to talk and she was like oh
whatever dude it's like I came all this
way to hear what you had to say and all
you could do is insult me no man even no
one is really bad but could rehash this
I love it
Jesus Christ it's a I've been personally
slighted man I get I get it no I mean I
think I'm being defamed all across this
now there's that there's a narrative
going around the progressive journalists
that has already been debunked by an
actual journalist called Tim pool and
the video evidence of the event that I
personally took that I stormed the stage
and started screaming Ibiza they're
saying that they'll probably who is
saying that journalist and like the
actual journalists like a lot of an
actual art well is Elmo now horrible
that said there probably aren't any yet
like that you tomorrow going on there
are articles about me and some of them
will say something like I abuse though
somehow fix it pause do you not
understand the irony of we're talking
about people labeling themselves as
victims and you are labeling yourself as
victim you have a crime that has not
occurred no I am asking about articles
that are being written by journalists
and videos that are being made but they
have not been made yet and then you're
saying just watch they're going to be
made yeah but less because I've been
going for a deep okay do you not see
come on you gotta be able to see that
well I I mean like I'm not like a victim
this is something that happened to me
but but do you get that oh yeah what I
was talking about right here I don't
know who is saying that you were stormed
that you storm the stage you tell me
journalists and I say where are these
articles and you say just wait
at a moment at the moment we're talking
about like rumors you know for example
like Tim Paul said that a friend of his
I think she's an actress but you know
it's the same sort of okay but that's
not la circles that's someone gossiping
yeah that doesn't mean that someone
actually a journalist wrote an article
about haven't yet warming the sample yet
how you why do you think they would want
social media why would you even
concentrate on that if it has not
occurred I mean isn't this sort of like
a lot guy complaining about the man
holding you back when there is no man
holding you back no I don't think it's
analogous I mean it is you're talking
about being a victim of a crime that
hasn't occurred no but I know what these
people are like I've been dealing with
them for long enough now I know what
those white people are like man I've
been dealing with them my whole life
yeah but we actually have a precedent
from doing this as well right but
they're not doing it right now and
you're saying they are they are their
own social media right now I mean like
you go like journalists like Ian miles
Chung who said right so the prevailing
narrative among journalists at the
moment is that Sargon's on stage and
abused Anita sarkeesian when video
evidence says the exact this is
something that isn't posted online
yeah a person so there's no articles but
there is a Twitter it's you can tell
that it's coming up their God their suit
out and then it was written this is how
these rumors start and then someone
starts reporting it and then suddenly
you get a narratives going on I mean I'm
not a victim of this because I've got a
large enough reach to build sake let's
change our videos I think people
listening to this who have no idea what
the [ __ ] are you are feeling is and
don't even know who you are they like
there's a lot of people listening to
this I would like to get to more
interesting things mm okay
did I say you're an interesting guy I
think I saw you a little wrapped up in
this right now okay I'm gonna send River
and all yeah you know I'll tell you what
it was but you're very smart guy your
videos are excellent you know and you
know so great thank you I can't wait to
Russ who's Russ your friend yeah he's a
huge fan Yas Sonny's Fanny on Russ
[Applause]
[Music]